I'll get the red lentil pasta really you
know how in mesino they ask you if it's
a true allergy or if it's just a
preference they say allergy or
preference I say preference because I
don't want to be annoying because you
say allergy they got like clean the
whole counter um could you look a little
more interested I'm telling a story so
when you tell it's so funny what it's
doing right now I'll tell you why you
don't act like this when we're hanging
out out there you know I'm nervous
around you we we out there in the world
dude I'm just kidding but this is like a
little disrespectful it's fine oh I'm
sorry sorry dude I kidding this is only
my third time you could do whatever you
want to do we're friends forever dude we
are I called you a chinless skeleton all
day before you even came here a
chinless dud if anybody is
chinless oh oh that
so what all I'm saying is ever since I
got Celia like I lost some weight and I
got a jawline now so what's up dude
maybe you know this was meant to be